hey 42 here about 130 million years ago
during the early cretaceous period
something rather unexpected happened
a flower bloomed this was undoubtedly
awkward for the planet involved nobody
had ever seen a flower before
the plants all around it were mosses and
seed-bearing
pines sick heads and ferns
they probably called the floral shrub
names and made jokes about the length of
its stamen
you know how cruel plants can be exactly
why
and how this happened is not entirely
clear
looking totally different from any other
vegetation at the time
and with no obvious evolutionary
ancestors
the emergence of flowering plants
remains a botanical conundrum
to this day in 1879 a grumpy charles
darwin called it
an abominable mystery what bugged him
was that flowering plants collectively
known as angiosperms
quite inconveniently didn't follow his
theory
of gradual evolution like hip-hop
artists
in the 1970s they appear to have arrived
from nowhere
and then grown quickly in volume and
diversity
in just a hundred million years
flowering plants
have conquered almost every habitat on
earth
today accounting for nine out of every
ten plant species on the planet
they have redefined the natural
landscape
and formed the foundation of new
ecosystems
and without them we'd all be on the
atkins diet
recently published research suggests
darwin was fretting over nothing
angiosperms quite possibly evolved
progressively
and over a suitably long period of time
though their relative fragility makes
finding them in the fossil record
harder than it is compared to say
dinosaurs
who let's face it could have stood to
lose a few pounds
still angiosperms eventual total
domination of the plant kingdom
remains one of nature's great success
stories
but let's not hype flowers too much they
couldn't have achieved this triumph on
their own
all the angiosperm in the world is
useless to you
if you can't even stroll over to another
plant and buy her a drink
no flowering plants need help to
reproduce
and no one has facilitated more
plant-on-plant action than the humble
bee
fossilized nests of bee or wasp-like
creatures
found in the petrified forest of arizona
date back around 220 million years
before flowers existed in the form we
know today
but scientists think that back then
there probably wasn't much of a buzz
between the blossoms and the bees
flowers were pretty ugly
and bees only went for cheerleaders but
at some stage plants appear to have
realized
they were missing a trick flowers began
to evolve to be
more attractive to flying insects
especially bees
90 to 100 million years ago they
developed petals
and started competing with each other to
lure the most pollinators
a process believed to be partially
responsible
for their rapid diversification and
colonization
of the earth in response bees changed
their shape
structure and behavior to optimize their
access to
pollen and nectar it's a famous story of
co-evolution
that has seen flowers and bees live in
mutually beneficial harmony
for millions of years until recently
that
is because the world's bees are dying
and nobody knows exactly why in
mid-november 2006
american beekeeper dave heckenberg made
a discovery
that would shake the beekeeping world in
a routine expection of his 2
400 hives he found 400 of them
totally abandoned the bees were gone
not dead gone like little buzzy ghosts
by february 2007 several large
beekeeping operations in the u.s
had reported similar cases with some
losing as many as 90 percent of their
colonies
similar disappearances had happened
throughout the history of beekeeping
also known as aquaculture with the first
recorded case dating back to 1869.
the phenomenon has been called by many
names over the years
including disappearing disease may
disease
or spring dwindle but what took place in
2006 was
unprecedented in its scale so
they gave it a new name colony collapse
disorder or ccd
the original name was going to be colony
upheaval
and neutralization tragedies but then
someone pointed out that the acronym was
rather problematic
what's really strange about condor i
mean ccd
is that there weren't any dead bees left
behind
just empty hives it's as if one morning
a lone worker bee said
screw this we work too hard i'm going to
mexico
and after some furious waggle dancing 80
bees followed him some newspapers
started referring to it
as the bee rapture whilst in the uk they
called it
mary celeste syndrome after the merchant
ship discovered off the azores
in 1872 with not a single passenger
aboard
i'll be covering that story in an
upcoming video by the way subscribe so
you don't miss it
for approximately the next nine years
ccd
claimed about a third of all bee
colonies in the united states
every year without anyone being able to
work out
exactly why and then it just
stopped we're not really sure why that
happened either
do we actually know anything but for
about the last five years
we haven't seen that particular set of
issues or at least not anywhere near to
the same extent
good news right unfortunately
not bee populations have continued
to nosedive with more than 30 percent of
tracked american honeybee colonies
dying off every year for the last decade
or so
up to around 40 percent last year and
the year before
but it's not only the us who are
experiencing this
it's a global trend han wang county
in china's sichuan province is known as
the pear capital of the world
but with local bee numbers in steep
decline the annual pollination
needed to ensure a full crop of fruit is
now done mostly by hand
one flower at a time and in germany
a decades-long study of protected nature
reserves
found that 75 of flying insects in these
areas
have died over the last 30 years or so
some scientists suggest that this is all
part of a wider mass extinction event
in which the majority of the planet
species will die off
this has happened five times before
that we're aware of and we could be
witnessing the six
right now after all populations of
animals all over the planet
are declining so rapidly that
researchers say we're in the process
of biological annihilation
that might seem hard to believe but only
because when people say
endangered animal you probably
automatically think of some big ticket
beasties like
tigers and rhinos but insects make up
around 90
of all species of animals on the planet
and more than half of all living things
there are approximately 1.4 billion
insects
for every human on earth but around the
world
that ratio is rapidly declining
the obvious question is why should you
care
nobody likes insects anyway right
especially ones like bees that can fight
back when you piss them off
but insects and particularly the bee
are crucial to human survival besides
the honeybee there are actually
25 to 30 000 different bee species
and they could all be suffering too that
matters
because without them we wouldn't have
most of the food we
eat on a daily basis remember the
flowering plants i mentioned earlier
they include the fruits vegetables and
crops
that make up the bulk of our natural
diet
and they're all pollinated by bees and
other
insects according to the un up to 75
percent of world food crops
depend on bees and other pollinators in
some way
whilst one international study estimates
the annual global food production that
depends on pollinators
is worth half a trillion dollars without
insects but especially bees our food
system
wouldn't necessarily collapse but many
more people
would go hungry we would still be able
to grow staples like grain and cereals
which are pollinated by the wind but
fruit and vegetables would be
unavailable
or unaffordable at a minimum you would
lose access to good nutrition
and most is a stuff that you like to eat
unless you're super rich
you'd probably have to start
familiarizing yourself with the symptoms
of scurvy
and you likely wouldn't be able to get
your hands on coffee
i'll let that one sink in for a moment
no
coffee beyond our human concerns
if all the bees died off the ripple
effects would be felt throughout most
major natural ecosystems without
pollinators
there will be fewer plants which would
ultimately mean less food
for most of earth's animal species and
more extinctions of
all kinds basically an armageddon of the
natural world
it's a pretty bleak picture so how do we
stop it from happening
first step of course is to diagnose the
problem
easier said than done since this is a
complex issue with many moving parts
and no it's not as some have suggested
caused by cell phones electromagnetic
radiation
a russian mind control experiment or
aliens
aliens really do get blamed for a lot of
stuff don't they
it's no wonder they never visit but
scientists have identified a number of
things that could be impacting the
populations
of all insect pollinators perhaps the
most obvious candidate is climate change
which impacts all ecosystems but there
isn't
yet much evidence to directly link
climate change to
insect die-off another concern is
habitat destruction
humans have a nasty tendency of taking
over natural environments to build
things they like
like car parks shopping malls and
starbucks
leaving less room for other species to
live and grow
strongly related to this is modern
agriculture
which sees increasing areas of land
usually forests
being cleared and repurposed to grow
food
in the last 50 years the human
population has nearly doubled
whilst the average calories consumed per
person has increased by about 30 percent
so we need more land to grow more food
there's a lot of debate about that
particular point not least because a lot
of the food we grow is being fed to
animals not people
about a third of all larable land in
fact is used to grow crops that feed
livestock
but that's a debate for another time or
just people who are quite a lot angrier
than i am
climate change and habitat destruction
can partly account for declining
populations of wild animals
but they don't sufficiently explain why
so many commercial and domestic
honeybees are dying
too they get all the pampering and
luxury they desire
to understand that we need to consider
the free peas
pesticides poor nutrition and parasites
to increase size and reliability of
yields
commercial farming relies heavily on the
use of pesticides
and insecticides it stands to reason
that bees being insects do not react
particularly well to these substances
but some are worse than others a
relatively new class of insecticides
neonicotinoids are used widely in
agriculture today
and may be outright deadly to bees
short-circuiting their memory and
navigation
as the name implies these chemicals have
an
unintentional nicotine-like addicting
effect on the bees
causing them to repeatedly come back for
more
other pesticides have less lethal
effects but they work to weaken bees
immune systems
making them more susceptible to disease
and parasites
making matters worse is a mass drop in
the quality of bee nutrition
left to its own devices your average
honey bee would spend its day
humming show tunes and flitting from
flower to flower
drinking nectar and collecting pollen
then it would fly home to its little
hive
where the nectar would be converted into
honey and the pollen would be used as a
protein food source
in the form of bee bread in this
scenario a bee might visit hundreds of
different flowers from different plants
every day enjoying a diverse diet in the
process
however modern farming methods tend to
favor monoculture
the practice of planting massive areas
of land with a single type of plant
at its worst this might be thousands of
hectares of farmland
planted with commercial crops like soy
or corn
that aren't pollinated by insects to a
bee
that's the equivalent of an empty
supermarket a food
desert that will effectively lead to
starvation
monocultures of flowering crops aren't
much better though
california produces 80 of the world's
almonds
with more than 1.4 million acres of land
dedicated to
almond trees and very little else
come spring there's a lot of almond
flowers and those need a lot of bees
every february an incredible 85
of all commercial bee colonies in
america
are taken to california for the single
largest managed pollination event
anywhere in the world the demand is so
great that even more hives are flown in
from countries like australia on the
surface it seems like bee
paradise hundreds of miles of almond
flowers
what more could a bee want but because
all the blossoms are from one
variety of plants the bees diet becomes
one-dimensional
lacking sufficient nutritional diversity
imagine if you only ate one thing
all day every day you wouldn't starve
but you wouldn't be very healthy either
even if that thing was broccoli
as a result b immune systems become
compromised
an effect made worse by the large
quantity of pesticides
used in the almond groves so with
pesticides and poor nutrition creating
weaker bees
the stage is set for the final p in our
puzzle
parasites and one vicious bastard in
particular
the vario destructor might this horror
story of a creature
is only about 1.2 millimeters long but
it's capable of doing some
serious damage it starts by climbing
onto the back of a bay
where it proceeds to wedge itself
between the plates of the bee's
once there it pierces the skin injecting
a cocktail
of digestive enzymes that gradually
liquefied the bee's insides providing
the might with an all-you-can-eat
bee smoothie buffet delicious
hives used to be able to withstand
various attacks
provided the infestation didn't
overwhelm more than 20 percent of the
colony
but nowadays with weakened immune
systems and pesticide
resistant strains of vario mite the
survival threshold
is only about three percent of the bee
population
after that the hive will be done for
and it's been happening more and more
for the past three decades
solving the b genocide issue isn't
rocket science
which is lucky because most of the
scientists working on the problem
are entomologists but it is a problem
that needs to be addressed
if your kids hope to be eating something
other than gruel
in 50 years time thanks for watching
you can now buy my new book stick a flag
in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below thank you